your theory on cookies and ponds for
example gas we talked about yesterday
the incredible event that we had here in
partnership with the st. Louis chess
club and today we have dr. art McCoy who
is a superintendent of the Jennings
school system and we also have a kid
whose name was going around everybody
wanted to play Bobby Lewis and there
with Murray's well yesterday was the
rest day and we got to all have a great
time going to the chess cops program and
wonderful initiative that has been
started by the Chess Club but going into
the schools and bringing police offers
to play against young people it was a
great great day and I have with me two
really great guests first of all dr. art
McCoy superintendent of Jennings welcome
to the show thank you so much I gotta
say that event was so so sweet I mean it
see all those police officers there in
uniform both city and county police so
many officials coming out it's it's like
everybody understood that this is an
important program that this is something
that was going to make a difference
I knew we see here on the monitor all
the great images there from the school
tell me what is chess for you you see
you there from yesterday as well
what does just mean to you and this
program mean to you and your schools
this program means the world to us I
mean first I have to say it was the
first time I ever had a board member and
my board president in tears crying
because they saw the beloved community
together as you mentioned police
officers business leaders elected
representatives officials chess
grandmasters and ultimately this chess
club who came out with such great
support it brought our stakeholders to
tears this means the world to us to have
our learning the global worldwide to
have people from as far as India come
over and other countries come to compete
and play and teach our students so chess
is all about strategy it's all about
confidence it's all about being able to
be a clear thinker and thinking about
your thinking that's what great schools
do they teach students how to think in a
mass
type of way and it was amazing to see
our students playing with cops playing
with Grand Master's playing with their
own community leaders and and winning in
many cases winning absolutely you know
and I can also see why you're running
the show definitely articulate those
benefits very very well we also have
with us of course this young man Bobby
Lewis jr. you know we got to compete
one-on-one me and Bobby as soon as I sat
down he said this is the fourth Grand
Master I ever play it's like okay now
I'm not about to try to lose Bobby we
had fun yesterday but tell me why do you
love chess so much I like to because
make you think strategize um lots of
read because the books and everything
how did you learn are you looking at
YouTube videos yes I actually watched
our video st. Louis YouTube eels really
who's your favorite um being feingold
then why do you like men be funny we
that's what we think about bed -
absolutely
now you see a young person like Bobby
he's a warm your heart to see him so
focused on the game and and others were
so focused for sure I mean Bobby is so
special and and his whole team he's been
a leader in the captain of his team his
team won like third place in our
regional chess competition against other
school districts and we were the only
junior high team to perform against high
school senior high school students so
you know it makes my heart proud to see
his pride his intelligence his ability
and being self-taught to play such a
strong game it that's really what we
want from all of our children but I'm
super proud of this young man because he
has excelled in so many ways that and he
has such grounded character that he
doesn't flaunt his smartness but he just
goes in confident and shows you on the
game itself on the campus well I tell
you I was able to beat Bobby in the
opening or medal game we went all the
way to an end game I to start picking
off some pawns this is some tech some
old man technique because this kid can
play but I do know that you got a draw
against Yassir in the side wall there
are a lot of fans watching who would
wish they could get a draw against
grandmasters 0
how'd you pull it off I don't know I
kind of had help from me I said I'm not
trying to be like very like I wonder I
drew first car I think he was a beat me
if we continue because you know how
grandma has to be and moving the Queen
and stuff and getting small advantages
but I'm happy I got a draw anyway I draw
the draw man put that in your book
anybody who draws yeah sincere one will
be very happy
what do you see if the future of this
chess program are you know we're gonna
expand it to make sure that neighboring
school districts are partnering with
this even though Spring Break for
instance I had officer Darren Young and
the Chess Club agreed to play chess with
Normandy students and Jennings during
our spring breaks and so we're just
gonna continue to grow it and grow it
from the current population of a few
hundred students to possibly thousands
of students because chess really does
make great thinkers and so we want our
football teams to continue to play chess
in between practices of plays because
it's all about strategies on the board
it's the same thing players and in other
sports but also in our science classes
stem classes we see chess in the
cafeteria so it's a matter of just
expanding and growing and showing them
the connections and all the disciplines
and good thinking Bobby what do you
think about what chess is doing in your
community you see all your friends
playing how does that make you feel to
see chess growing as you love it so much
because like not have other players
people to play against the more the
merrier indeed well we love it it's such
a great program and you guys are doing
great work representing the community
well dr. art McCoy the superintendent of
the Jennings School District a real
leader in the community as well as Bobby
Lewis jr. remember that name that gets
dangerous expect great things from you
in the future young man thank you thank
you